now to a story commemorating Holocaust
Remembrance Day today is Holocaust
Remembrance Day marking 78 years since
the liberation of the Auschwitz
concentration camp in Nazi occupied
Poland six million Jews were killed in
the Holocaust and as survivors get older
their first-hand accounts are becoming
rarer and rarer drica Duncan met up with
two survivors to learn about their
stories and a special project they're
working on in the kitchen to keep their
Traditions alive drika good morning good
morning good morning to all of you food
of course is one of the best ways to
experience culture not only are we using
our senses to take us back in time but
oftentimes we're in the kitchen
listening to stories as we're preparing
those recipes and stories that let us
know what it was like and why we should
never forget about the past
for 84 year old Tova Friedman there's
one ingredient that matters most during
Friday night Shabbat dinner
family
three generations gathered around the
dining room table it's a dream that
Friedman never imagined would be
possible as a five-year-old in Auschwitz
birkenau concentration camp where more
than one million people died are you
sometimes surprised that you survived
the Holocaust
yes and no because being a child I
didn't think about survival or not
survival I was more concentrating on
Surviving every hour in every hour
every day was like wow I'm still here
it's a fear that 84 year old Eugene
ganter also endured his first six years
of life were spent in that same
extermination camp they shaved me from
here all the way back they took all the
hair out so only here on the sides
remained and they did it to every
prisoner and we were halfway through the
gas chamber and he says halt about face
and my father who spoke perfect German
he found out that they had gotten orders
because the Russians were so close
that they were only to burn the bodies
of the dead but not to guess anymore
because of the evidence so you were
minutes away from dying yes
how do you remember the details so well
because these memories are so
vibrant so vivid I could close my eyes
as a child and if I heard the boots
of the Germans I can tell you which
German it was somebody to be feared or
somebody is who safe
the sights and sounds of genocide never
left them neither did the feeling of
starvation when people say to me what
did you think in Auschwitz food I dreams
about food food was a constant thought
and it was connected with life or death
all the time what was the worst for me
was The Thirst
when I was on a transport
and there was three days without water
that really that stuck with me to this
day that I still have I have to have
some water nearby so
you know
I have to have some water because it
gets to me do you remember your first
real meal after Liberation in Auschwitz
there was this terrible smell of burning
bodies
permeated everywhere
but then I began to smell another smell
and I said to say after The Liberation
what is that she said that's the making
of bread I still remember that how did
those experiences shape who you are
today oh
achieved me completely
I made my life a monument sort of of
what of of what it will try to kill four
children and grandchildren I tried to
resurrect that which Hitler wanted to
destroy
after Liberation in 1945 they both
eventually settled in the U.S they've
been building their lives through the
families they've created just amazing
and the Traditions they're passing On to
the Next Generation like Jewish recipes
their favorite dishes are featured and
this new cookbook honey cake and latkes
recipes from the old world
Friedman and genter met while working on
the book published by the Auschwitz
birkenau Memorial Foundation it includes
more than 100 Holocaust Survivor stories
paired with family recipes Food reminds
you of your family and the love like the
cheesecake or the papka that my mother
would make you know it brings back the
memories of the love that she was
transferring food was always so internal
food are always people in some way
on it here we go
so I joined Friedman and genter in the
kitchen to learn a thing or two about
making Kasha varnishkas
I like them for me it's a comfort food
as children of the Holocaust Friedman
and genter know their stories will soon
fade but their hope is that the lessons
learned from such an atrocity will not
help people understand and connect the
dots to why survivors like yourselves
are fearful that something like the
Holocaust could happen again I'm fearful
to be that it can't happen again because
most people don't know any history
they're not aware of what happened what
do you want people to remember about the
Holocaust my story can be duplicated by
a million and I have children who are
murdered I was just lucky
I feel almost obligated to talk about
them it's like I am bringing them back
from their ashes because I represent
them
and we thank Mrs Friedman and Mr Ginter
for sharing those stories we wanted to
share one of the recipes from the book I
can't promise you it was the you know I
didn't put my foot in it as I did at the
last time
this is a chocolate sandwich and Mr
genter said his mother made him this to
fatten him up after Liberation because
he was so thin and frail so usually it's
like a black bread what is it it's a rye
bread usually this is a wheat bread but
it's butter and then you just put some
chocolate you shave chocolate on top of
it butter on bread and chocolate this is
a winner bread butter chocolate it's a
pretty good combination it's very simple
but when you think about what they were
going through at that time this would
make sense you know a lot of those pasta
dishes bread dishes that's why it's so
important to tell these stories and when
anybody doubt what the Holocaust it's
maddening did you by chance bring any
challah bread I love Holograms holla
back
I just love food is live this book comes
out in September you can find it
wherever you like to buy your books
thank you Jimmy Carter